ما ان تم الاعلان عن انهيار ثلاثه بنوك
امريكيه في اسبوع واحد وتشكيلها لاول ازمه
ماليه بهذا الحجم منذ العام 2008 بدات
اصابع الاتهام تتجه نحو من قد يكون
المتسبب بهذه الازمه بعض الخبراء رمي
المسؤوليه على الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
الامريكي وقراراته المتاخره بمعالجه
الازمات فبعد اتهامات للاحتياطي الفيدرالي
بانه تاخر كثيرا في تدارك ازمه ارتفاع
التضخم بعدم رفعه لاسعار الفائده بوتيره
سريعه اظهرت ازمه البنوك المنهاره ثغره
كبيره في مهام الفيدرالي واهمها الرقابه
على البنوك
فقبل اكثر من عام من سقوط بنك اس في بي
عين الاحتياطي الفيدرالي فيسكو فريقا
لمعينه اصول البنك واطلق الفريق المتخصص
انذارات عده ومطالبه باصلاحات هامه في بنك
اس بي بي وبهايه العام الماضي طالب الفريق
باصلاحات شامله لمواجهه مخاطره ارتفاع
الفائده واثرها على ميزانيه البنك من جهه
اخرى جاءت تنظيمات القطاع المالي في عهد
الرئيس السابق ترامب والتي خففت قيود
الافصاح على البنوك التي تتجاوز اصولها
250 مليار دولار عاملا اخر في ازمه سقوط
البنوك الثلاثه خاصه بعد اعفائها من بعض
القيود على راس المال المتوفر لديها
واستثنائها من اختبارات فحص جهد المالي
وفي تطور لافت وفي اواخر العام 2021
تعيين نائب رئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي في
سان فرانسيسكو جريجوري والمسؤول عن رقابه
بنك اس بي بي انذاك لاستلام مهمه اخرى
تمثلت بان يكون المسؤوله عن الجهه
التنظيميه في بنك سيلفر غيت الذي تعثر هذا
الشهر ايضا بيكر الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك اس
بي بي قام قبل اسبوعين من سقوط البنك ببيع
اسهم في البنك بثلاثه ملايين الف دولار
وهو يخضع حاليا لتحقيق من وزاره العدل
لقيامه بذلك
تماسك البنكي بسندات قديمه ذات عائد منخفض
جدا لوقت الاستحقاق مقابل فوائد اكبر
يدفعها على ودائع العملاء كان كفيلا بسقوط
مدن اشعله اندفاع العملاء لسحب ودائعهم من
البنك
شادي الزعيم العربيه